let's explore the fluid mosaic model of
cell membranes
now why is it called the fluid mosaic
model well if we were to look at a cell
membrane and just to be clear what we're
looking at if this is a cell right over
here if this is a cell and this is its
membrane this is the membrane it's kind
of what keeps the cell the inside of the
cell separated from whatever is outside
the cell we're looking at a cross
section of its surface
we're looking at a cross section of its
surface we're down here
down here this is inside the cell if we
look at it relative to this diagram this
is inside the cell and this is outside
this is outside and when you zoom in
when you zoom in this this little part
right over here this is actually a
phospholipid
bilayer that forms it and so when you
hear that you might say well what is a
phospholipid and that's a good question
because when you understand what a
phospholipid is it starts to make sense
why it would form a bilayer like this
and why it's the basis for so many
membranes and biological systems so this
is indicative of a phospholipid and as
its name implies and let me write that
down this is a phospho phospholipid
it's a lipid that involves a phosphate
group and in general the word lipid and
we have a whole video on lipids means
something that that doesn't dissolve
well so well in water and that's true is
the case of this phospholipid you have
these hydrocarbon tails that are coming
from fatty acids and so these
hydrocarbon tails
they have no obvious charge or no
obvious polarity we know that water is a
polar molecule that's what gives us its
hydrogen bonds and it's attracted to
itself but these don't have those and so
they're they're not going to be
attracted to the water and the water is
not going to be attracted to it to them
and so that these tails are hydrophobic
so you have hydrophobic
hydrophobic
tails
and these are really kind of the lipid
part of the phospholipids and then you
have the phosphate head
you have the phosphate head
right over here and as you can clearly
see this has some charge charged
molecules do well in polar substances
like water they're going to dissolve
well and so this part right over here is
going to be hydrophilic
hydro
hydrophilic
and actually molecules that have a
hydrophilic part and a hydrophobic part
there's a special word for them
amphipathic a word that i sometimes have
trouble saying
so phospholipids are amphipathic
amphipathic which means that they have
both a hydrophilic end a part that is
attracted to water and a hydrophobic end
that is not attracted to water and
hopefully that starts to explain why
they organize themselves in this way
because you can imagine the hydrophilic
heads are going to want to be where the
water is which is going to be either
outside the cell or inside the cells and
the tails are hydrophobic the water is
going to go away from them or they're
going to go away from the water and so
they're just going to face each other
and they're going to be on the inside of
the membrane but the really cool thing
is a structure like this having this
amphipathic molecule allows things like
these bilepid these these lipid bilayers
i should say to form it's actually
fascinating if
we think that if you go far back enough
even before
life in cellular form formed that you
might have had phospholipids
spontaneously forming these these
spheres of that where you have a bilayer
a lipid bilayer so you can imagine
something let me see if i drew a cross
section
let me see if i could draw it
relatively neatly so
i think i'll draw half of it just
because you get well i'll draw the whole
thing
hopefully you get the idea so that would
be
one layer of the phosphate heads
facing the outside this is the inner
layer
and i'm doing a cross section right over
here and then you have your hydrophobic
tails
so your hydrophobic tails let me do that
in a different color so your hydrophobic
your hydrophobic tails i think you get
the picture we have a bunch of
hydrophobic tails
on either end and you could
spontaneously form a structure like this
which starts to feel like hey well maybe
there's a protocell forming and
obviously to actually have real life you
have to have some form of information
that can be passed on and you have to
have some type of metabolism and the
cell is living in all of the definitions
of life but at least this basic
structure of the cellular membrane you
can imagine how it forms in kind of a
in a pre-life state even by by virtue of
amphipathic molecules like a
phospholipid so fair enough we're able
to form this phospholipid bilayer but
what are all these other things that i
have drawn here well these are proteins
and these are examples of
so this is a protein right over here
this is a protein this is a protein and
i just drew some kind of blobs to be
indicative of the variety of proteins
but the important thing to realize is is
when you think of cells there's all of
this diversity there's all of this
complexity that is on or embedded inside
of its membrane so instead of just
thinking of it just kind of as a uniform
phospholipid bilayer there's all sorts
of stuff there's all sorts of stuff
maybe if we view this as a cross section
there's all sorts of stuff embedded in
it
and
we see it right over here in this
diagram you could say there's a mosaic
of things embedded in it a mosaic is a
is a picture made up of a bunch of
different components of all different
colors and you can see that you have all
different different components here
different types of proteins the you have
proteins like this that go across the
membrane we call these transmembrane
proteins they're a special class of
integral proteins you have integral
proteins like this that might only
interact with one part of the the
bilayer while these kind of go across it
you have things like glycolipids so this
right over here this is a glycolipid
glycoglycolipid
which is fascinating it lodges itself in
the membrane because it has this lipid
end so that's going to be hydrophobic
it's going to get along with all the
other hydrophobic things but then it has
an end that's really a that's a a
chain of sugars and that part is going
to be hydrophilic it's going to sit
outside of the cell and these chains of
sugars these are actually key for cell
cell recognition your immune system uses
these to differentiate between which
cells are the ones that are actually
from my body the ones that i don't want
to mess with the ones i want to protect
and which cells are the ones that are
foreign the ones that i might want to
attack when people talk about blood type
they're talking about well what type of
specific glycolipids do you have on
certain on on cells and there's all
sorts of and that's that's not all we're
talking about when we talk about
glycolipids as kind of a way for cells
to to be recognized or to be tagged in
different ways so it's a fascinating
thing that these chains of sugars are
can lead to such complex behavior and
frankly such useful behavior from our
point of view but you don't just have
you don't mind just have sugar chains on
lipids you also have sugar chains on
proteins this right over here is an
example of a glycoprotein
glycoglycoprotein
and as you can see when you put all this
stuff together you get a mosaic and i'm
actually not even done there you have
things like cholesterol embedded
cholesterol is a lipid so it's going to
sit in the hydrophobic part of the
membrane and that actually helps with
the fluidity of the membrane making sure
it's not too fluid or not too or not too
stiff so this is cholesterol
cholesterol right over there so you see
this
mosaic of stuff but what about the fluid
part and i just talked about
cholesterol's value and making sure that
it's just the right amount of fluidity
what's neat about this is this isn't a
rigid structure if if this thing were to
be jostled around a little bit or maybe
it would be plucked out somehow the
phospholipids would just spontaneously
rearrange to fill in the gap you can
imagine these things are all flowing
around that this membrane actually has a
consistency of kind of of of of oil or
salad dressing so it isn't this this you
know it isn't like a a rubbery texture
like you might imagine a membrane like a
balloon it's actually fluid these things
can move around but it has but even
though it's fluid it's good enough to
separate the two environments the the
environment inside the cell from the
environment outside of the cell
and that's where the name fluid mosaic
model comes from